エアーフレーバー360
[音楽]
いつもお世話になっているを持つ親実買わせていただきましたを貼っ
おねえさんいつもありがとうございます簡単にお姉さんによりましたよこのおもちゃ
youtube に出すの
多分楽しみにしてるねはいありがとうありがとうございますいつも行ってるお前さんの
おばあちゃんおねえさんを見てるのでちょっと緊張してますでこれなんですけど何が
すごいかっていうともどう見てもアレですよブーメランのそれなイメージだと猫切ると
思ってたんですよあげるとそれを嘆いてそれ故うーん
ヒカキンさんが釣ってあげるとこうねそのままボリング十勝でそれ操作できるかと思っ
ブーブーことでウードゥ
ん
ああああああああ
発達打つ打ってきました何を止まる取り出しましょう繊細な頭大丈夫かなぁこんな感じ
で本当にですめっちゃ軽いここだけプロペラがついてるんですこれ高回転するんだと
思いますこれがコントローラーです
b でもコーン完全に bd 持ったこれで充電するのかな
ホラー
プラスドライバーを使いいただけます padi オープンループ
ok ターン3点仕掛ける後輩覇王がに33展示
がーうーキロ日これでつかないパターンがよくあるから
2つは確かめましょうついてついてバッチリちゃんとしておりますこれで多分動くね
ちゃんとネジをとちっっ
ああああああ
もうもきますキタコレ
me
はぁっやばいやばいやばいじゃないよ
あっはぁこれ力の加減だなん
まって結構痛かったよ
はぁ
俺多分なんですけどう電車内からまでま
以下充電しまった
これだけれるんじゃねぇ
[音楽]
[拍手]
フォーゼ
[音楽]
すごっ
はぁ
zone
あやべ地位でちゃった
[音楽]
voodoo
しています